[Música]
[Aplausos]
hum
no início do século existe um poeta
nordestino chamados é da luz e zé da luz
uma vez escutou desaforo e que ele não
podia falar de amor que ele não podia
falar de sentimento por não ter um
português correto sofisticado um
português bem desistido da luz fez um
poema chamado ice sei se diz assim se um
dia nós se gostasse
se um dia nós sequer esse
se nós dois sem parar ea si sejam narda
viver-se sejam que não demorasse sejam
de 92 drome se exijam que nós dois no
recife
se o céu nós a subir cimar porém se
acontecesse de são pedro não abrisse a
porta do céu e fosse de executar tudo
isso e se eu me agarrei me nascido com
ele insiste para que eu resolvesse a
minha faca eu puxar se do céu furasse a
ver com os dois ficassem sabendo que nós
dois cais e ossel furado a riace e as
virgens todas foi giz uma salva de
palmas é da luiz poeta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bom dia meu povo soubesse eu vim aqui do
alto santo mas ben ali no vale do
jaguaribe e eu assim como zé da luz
também houve muitos nãos e assim como
diz o poeta nordestino chamado petrúcio
amorim o não tem poder trouxe o diz 15
constrói mas não constrói muito mais
eu vi muitos nãos como foi que eu vim
parar aqui neste palco pelo segundo ano
consecutivo abrindo o tek fortaleza como
palestrante mas eu nunca pensei nesse
negócio de ser palestrante
em 2011 eu tive um sonho de usar as
redes sociais da internet pra leva a
cultura popular nordestina e poesia para
milhões de pessoas e isso aconteceu em
um ano um projeto de alcançar 20 milhões
de pessoas
lá do alto um cabo que ligou de maceió e
disse brown e bessa apae mas você sem
sair de uma cidade de 18 mil habitantes
no interior do ceará criou um movimento
virtual que causa impacto social e
cultural e mais de ficar milhões de
pessoas por mês
além disso um negócio muito bonito ele
diz cara você é um grande empreendedor
social
achei massa porque eu não sabia que eu
era o meu deus ou em seguida diz um
negócio mais bonito ainda
ele diz rapaz você tem um grande case de
sucesso é o fraco é amiga do teu tenho
aquele momento eu descobri que eu era um
tal do empreendedor social com grande
case de sucesso e nem eu sabia
ele disse olhe vai acontecer um evento
nacional para estudantes 1.500
estudantes três dias de congresso
palestrantes renomados do brasil
você não tem uma palestra não na mesma
hora eu disse tenho e é boa porque toda
a minha frente não pensa numa palestra
boa aí mente mas ela tenha palavra nunca
nem assistido um
porque rafael com cinco taças sua
palestra no evento eu disse rocha
eu fui atrevido mais pra frente
no outro dia estava me ligou não de sal
as salas brown queria só confirma a 2 o
dono observações aqui com você do evento
onde se pode dizer eles rafael que é o
seguinte é são três dele congresso é a
organização exigiu que a sua palestra
tivesse uma hora e meia de duração era
daqui a 14 dias do evento
aí eu respirei fundo porque se eu
aprendi uma coisa que a gente não pode
perder na vida é a pose
não porque meu amigo acaba com a cabeça
erguida ver o fim do episódio em si me
imagino acaba campeão
bom eu respirei fundo disse
uma hora e meia são eles é rapaz algum
problema eu disse não a minha palavra
tem duas horas mas vou cortar mesmo para
se adaptar o evento de vocês na memória
o crédito ressalta o homem é bom empatar
qual é o problema só ele sabe até porque
infelizmente não tem cachê pra você
ora mais aquilo partiu meu coração de
liso e eu sabendo que tinha para a
estância neste congresso com cachês de
40 mil reais
aí eu pensei vão me pagar pelo menos 400
na hora eu respirei fundo de novo eu
disse como essa alta não tem cachê
ele começou a narrar é porque não sei o
que eu tenho aqui é o de salvar pará
eu vou dizer uma coisa você me escute
bem e não é tudo na vida não só pelo
amor de deus
na mesma hora talvez o homem barricou
maggi e aí eu fui a primeira palestra
mas aí vim parar aqui hoje é dois anos
seguidos
aprendi também a palestra no texas e aí
vem o ratão no brasil todo de lá pra cá
não parei mais
eu tenho um sonho e leva à cultura que
leva à poesia comecei a fazer poesia e
gravar com o celular e postar na
internet
há muito que a palavra transforma que a
poesia transforma e quando eu conhecia a
obra de patativa do assaré com 14 anos
eu comecei a literatura de cordel
com 14 anos de idade e eu disse eu quero
ser como patativa eu quero transformar
vidas através depois e comecei a postar
isso na internet repente os vídeos já
tinham milhões de visualizações até que
um dia eu recebi um e mail do programa
encontro com farinha é fato bernard pra
vocês me convidando para ir lá falar
sobre o trabalho sobre a minha luta pela
cultura do nordeste enfim e eu não
consegui eu fiz a participação pela
internet é uma participação de 5 minutos
pela internet eu lá no alto santo e na
hora que começou o programa internet
travou mas deu 78 dias chegou a meio pau
vir aqui falar sobre o jeito do nordeste
no seio de na hora fui e fiquei na
platéia na primeira fila da platéia
conversei cinco minutos com fátima
bernardes falei da nossa cultura falei
do nosso povo assim na platéia mesmo foi
cinco minutos beleza foi com 15 dias
ligaram a bola vai trazer o joão vitor
iniciaram esse aqui de fortaleza teve a
maior nota do enem daquele ano
cv para falar sobre essa força de
vontade do povo nordestino e tal e vou
na hora que cheguei eu tava no cantinho
assim alguém da produção chegou pra mim
e só hoje você vai por sofá e vai
participar do programa todo mundo lascar
mas na hora que saiu assim o mal day
antes de ficar nervoso que revê maldade
em tudo na hora eu pensei rapaz
a primeira vez eu fiz pela internet
a segunda na platéia a terceira no sofá
eles vão tirar a fátima
vão não me observando
[Aplausos]
ae
aí é o fim imagem eu sentei naquele sofá
ou sentei no sofá do encontro com
atrizes consagradas com atores com
fátima bernardes que é um ícone e
naquele momento eu fiz uma prece e de
romã do coração vem a seguinte mensagem
aqui eu não sou melhor do que ninguém eu
não sou inferior a ninguém vale mais do
que nós somos iguais então você ou mesmo
eu não vou me dobrar e você de verdade
e foi por isso que deu certo eu declamou
um poema nesse de estar dois anos e meio
e há dois anos e meio toda sexta feira
com um poema para milhões de pessoas na
televisão
isso é uma conquista nossa da nossa
cultura que tem um carro aqui do alto
santo que escreve poesia nordestina
poesia popular por dia para o povo e tem
um espaço na maior emissora de tv do
país toda semana
hoje eu tenho um quadro chamado por dia
com rapadura e eu comecei a observar o
impacto que isso tem na vida das pessoas
que a poesia transforma
de repente as pessoas começaram a me
parar na rua e dá depoimentos que a
princípio me abalaram muito de forma
positiva mas de pessoas por exemplo que
a opa eu escrevi tudo no programa são
mais de 80 temas toda semana tenho que
escrever sobre alguma coisa que eu não
sei eu recebo um tema na quinta-feira na
quarta eu escrevi chego lá e tenho que
dar com uma mão e eu já escrevi sobre a
homofobia sobre racismo sobre depressão
sobre suicídio sob transfobia sobretudo
em forma de poesia em forma de
literatura de cordel isso também é
quebrar um mito sobre a própria poesia
sobre o cordel que a gente pode falar de
tudo a gente pode transformar em lei a
receber depoimentos de pessoas por
exemplo que dizia que a água não
depressão profunda e que decidida a
tirar a própria vida ao receber um poema
meu note zap e desistiu de pessoas que
houve um poema meu falando orgulho de
ser nordestino e
quebrou o preconceito de pessoas como eu
vi lá no palco no programa falar sobre
violência contra a mulher e um
especialista nos moldes especialista no
assunto se que um dos casos mais
complicados dele procurou com meus
poemas um homem que era extremamente
agressivo com a mulher ele parou fica a
poesia transforma realmente eu
selecionei as cirurgias eu fiz um post
no no facebook quando estava preparando
a minha fala pra cá e eu
se a minha poesia já lhe fez algum bem
me conte a sua história eu postei porque
eu queria vê-la em cento e poucas
histórias selecionar duas talvez pra
compartilhar com vocês
o posto teve 5 mil e poucos comentários
e eu comecei a ler
eu me emocionei eu eu lembrei aqui dois
que eu queria compartilhar com vocês
o primeiro viu pessoa que disse que
quando eu declarei um poema sobre mãe no
dia das mães ela há 27 anos não falava
com a mãe e ela ouviu aquele poema e
saiu foi direto na casa da mãe ela pediu
perdão à mãe perdoou
elas se abraçaram elas riram elas
choraram assistindo o poema de novo e
21de depois disso a mãe dela faleceu e
ela agradeceu pela poesia ter
transformado o último dia de vida da mãe
dela em dias felizes
é um poema que disse assim eu vou dizer
pra vocês aqui
a palmada da mãe não dói metade das
palmadas que a vida da gente disse
os mais sábios conselhos ela me deu sem
tirar nem botar acertou tudo é doutora
da vida sem estudo foi vivendo que
ensinou e que aprendeu com as pancadas
dessa vida mãe sofreu e mostrou até de
forma inconsciente que seus filhos
precisavam ser decentes e viver sempre
com honestidade
a palmada da mãe não da metade das
palmadas que a vida dá se a carne era
pouca e o caldo ralo o pirão do amor que
em substância e as panelas toda cheia de
esperança nossa fé nunca sofreu nenhum
abalo mãe dizia filho escute o que eu te
falo nessa vida seja sem paciência
cada um tem um estilo diferente de luta
e cresça mas nunca perca a humildade a
palmada da mãe não vai metade das
palmadas que a vida da gente se um
presente mais bonito ele pedia e mãe
dizia que não podia me dar
eu me enganava e começava a chorar sem
saber que muito mais nela doía
sem dinheiro a fazer minha alegria
inventava uma maneira diferente e dizia
que um dia lá na frente meu trabalho
matar essa vontade
a palmada da manhã e tarde das palmadas
que a vida da gente toda a vida que eu
cheiro nela agradeço a deus por ter
minha mãezinha mais você que já perdeu
sua rainha não se sinta só em um
distante dela entre a terra eo céu há
uma janela com um vaso onde deus planta
semente do amor que a mãe da gente sente
essa rosa nos protege da maldade
a palmada da manhã da metade das
palmadas que a vida da imagem
[Música]
obrigado
e aí meu povo eu comecei a ler estes
comentários e tal e fui vendo inúmeros
casos um poema que escreveu isso o
professor por exemplo a quantidade de
professores que me agradeceu e disse que
estava desmotivado com aquele poema
ganhou força novamente muita coisa mas
tem um poema que eu escrevi sobre a vida
e não foi só pra minha vida foi sobre a
nossa eu falo de forma muito sincera e
muito humano que eu acredito realmente
que seja o ofício de viver em meio a
tantas mensagens que recebi de pessoas
agradecendo por aquele poema de ta com
força de pessoas porque uma senhora que
disse que quem sai do consultório com
diagnóstico de câncer e na televisão na
recepção eu estava dizendo expoema
naquele dia saiu de lá dizendo que tinha
certeza que ia vencer e 12 e depois foi
de um dos sobreviventes do desastre com
a chapecoense do uma o jogador
ele me mandou uma mensagem dizendo que
aquele poema deu muita força para ele
naquele momento e eu comecei a
quantidade de depoimentos e depois mesmo
em relação a esse poema específico então
eu também preciso compartilhar ele com
vocês é um poema que eu falo de vida que
diz assim
sendo eu um aprendiz
a vida já me ensinou que besta é quem
vive triste
lembrando que faltou magoando as
cicatrizes esquece de ser feliz por tudo
que conquistou
afinal meu povo afinal nem toda lágrima
setor
nem toda graça sorriso nem toda curva da
vida tem uma placa de aviso e nem sempre
que você perde é de fato prejuízo
o meu ou seu caminho não são muito
diferentes em spin pedra buraco pra mode
atrasar a gente não desanime por nada
pois até uma topada o povo você pra
frente
acredito no poder da palavra desistir
tiro de coloque um r que você tem
resistir é uma pequena mudança que nos
enche de esperança e faz a gente seguir
continue sendo forte
tenha fé no criador é também você ver
não tenha medo da dor se enfrenta
caminhada e sabe que a cruz mais pesada
o filho de deus carregou
[Música]
[Aplausos]
então a minha luta é essa é de usar a
poesia de usar a cultura para
transformar vidas
isso tem feito o resultado eu continuar
toda semana na televisão na internet na
minha palestra por onde quer que eu vá
eu tento espalhar essa mensagem que
também causa impacto na querem mostrar
não mas os meus vídeos os vídeos com os
poemas são os vídeos mais assistidos da
plataforma online puxou toda semana
publicado toda semana o vídeo mais
assistido inclusive um vídeo que foi de
das mães que teve um alcance de 33
milhões de pessoas e é um dos vídeos
mais assistidos da história da
plataforma isso é pois irmãs na
televisão é poesia eu lancei meu livro
eu não sei um livro e esse livro me
proporcionou experiências incríveis
experiências de está na fila do a noite
é o top passar oito horas autografando o
livro de poesia no país decidiu
estimular a leitura e eu passar oito
horas autografando o livro de poesia e
dessa mesma fila vem o pai que traz o
filho de cinco anos seis anos de idade
que queria estar ali que chega com meus
poemas decorado e diz que vai ser o
primeiro livro dele e aí quando o
autógrafo de um cheiro e sai o próximo
da fila é um filho trazendo um pai de 80
anos e 84 a mãe de 90 que diz que faz 20
anos que não leu um livro que quer
voltar lá e por causa disso
então acredito realmente que a poesia
transforma transforma a vida das pessoas
e transformar a minha quando eu conheci
a poesia de patativa do assaré poeta
cearense como eu que eu quero encerrar
se fala com esse poema dele que eu
carrego na minha pele na minha alma é um
poema que fala do socialista que diz
assim
eu sou de uma terra que o povo padece
mas não esmorece procura vencer da terra
querida que além da cabocla de riso na
boca sombra no sofrer
não nego meu sangue não nego meu nome eu
olho pra fome e pergunta o que há
eu sou brasileiro filho do nordeste sou
cabra da peste
sou do ceará muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aí eu disse
ele veio de alto santo interior do ceará
a espalhar aos quatro cantos nossa
cultura popular e hoje esse luxo
brasileiro veio comemorar o neto de 10 a
pateiro o fazedor de poesia o poeta
verdadeiro que só nos dá alegria resgata
a nossa beleza repartir conosco seu dia
então aqui vai uma surpresa bom fazer um
escarcéu nutec fortaleza
esse cabo do chapéu batam palmas com
firmeza para encerrar esse cordel
[Aplausos]
parabéns pra você
clique nela
senhoras e senhores uma salva de palmas
para bráulio bessa
[Aplausos]